shut up in your face all right
body camera video shows the aftermath of
a so-called citizen's arrest that could
lead to charges for a Colorado father
and son after they allegedly beat a
homeless man you know how he got the
blood out was that already
so he was trying to resist it a little
bit and uh my son right here he must
have heard too though
and help put him to the ground so so
yeah okay it happened on September 14th
of last year but investigators in Pueblo
Colorado reopened the investigation last
month that's when surveillance video was
made public showing 56 year old Doug
Cullison and his son Nate Cullison
beating the homeless man later
identified as Alex Montoya body camera
video shows officers arriving on the
scene to find the pair restraining
Montoya what's going on guys so he
punched the school teacher over Parkview
and then uh I was going down the street
had to be my wife over there and we have
a picture from the school let's see the
school secretary
and of course I think you already have
that call probably yeah but uh
just getting ready to start Montoya can
be seen in the video with blood covering
his face he begins to cry as the
responding office officer asks him about
the injury
up in your face all right
okay you want Rescue
a fat cheek and some blood coming out of
his mouth in speaking to Doug Collison
officials learn what led up to montoya's
injuries he says Montoya was at a nearby
school and punched his wife so what uh
what exactly happened man so my wife is
a schoolteacher over that Parkview I'm
also a part-time guy at the Sheriff's
Office okay so just a part-time guy
they're SWAT medic okay so my wife
called me she's like hey this guy is you
know right in front of the building and
we told him to leave so he started
throwing whatever throwing something or
punching cars at the front of Parkview
so then she called me back for about
five minutes late it was like hey he
just punched me so I'm like okay well go
inside and let you have kids out front
go inside and you know get out of his
way
so then I I caught up at the front and
they're like hey he just started walking
down 9th Street so I'm like okay so
I got this my Jeep site
driving on 9th Street just so I can keep
an eye on him so I'm gonna call you guys
hey this is this is where the smoke head
is uh I went over to the school over
here whatever that
school is done here on Ninth and I gave
them a heads up to the road crossing
folks it's like hey FYI
this guy was acting crazy in front of
Parkview so I just in case he comes down
here and I gave that information to one
of the
Crossing people okay so let me get in
front of your body camera so you get
that I hear you so then uh
I texted one of the school crossing the
employees and I said Hey in case you see
this guy just be aware
uh she called me right back and said hey
he's at eighth in Glendale so I said oh
okay great let me come walking down here
driving down here so I saw him probably
at whatever that other
cross back cross street okay so I just
pulled up here because I was going hey
you know
see where he's going or whatever so uh
so I did try to detain him here just
until you guys showed up and uh
here we go so the thing that did it is
in the back of that car yeah they took
them to the ground and the process
taking the ground he said he landed on
his face he's got like a swollen cheek
and blood on his mouth
um says that that happened from that he
works part-time at DSO okay there's a
medic over there and stuff so as
officers search Montoya he says he
didn't mean to hurt the teacher party's
here saying this is uh the male and
punch the teacher okay
[Music]
okay we'll we'll figure it out dude when
asked how Montoya hurt his face Cullison
admits a struggle took place hey do you
know how he got the blood out was that
already on there so he was trying to
resist it a little bit and uh my son
right here he must have heard too though
and helped put him to the ground so so
yeah Collison then tells officials he
was searching through montoya's backpack
before they arrived I saw his stuff all
his stuff so okay including the red
backpack yeah all that so I did pull
that out of his pockets because I didn't
know if he had a weapon or anything how
you doing so I did pull out of his
pocket initially then I was getting
ready to do some Medical on him okay
until you showed up and then okay that's
the reason I took his backpack off and I
just started going through his pockets
right before he got here just because I
I don't know weapons you know what I'm
saying he also says his wife plans to
press charges against Montoya okay I
don't know if she was sitting at all did
she want to press charges you know or
like a picture
yeah
I'm sorry
um I actually wanted medical attention
over there she said no her daughter
pretty better
[Music]
they wanted him trespassed yeah they
wanted to trespassed and uh definitely a
citation
a school resource officer explains he
spoke with cullison's wife about the
incident at the school so this is what
she told me to ask but she said he was
sitting outside the front of the
building charging his phone attempting
to smoke something to know what
um they confronted him he starts
spitting on people on their clothing
that's right spitting on their clothing
so once they start spitting on their
clothing they're supposed to believe
this didn't no spit made contact to any
he started yelling he started punching
vehicles
um he ended up punching his wife in the
mouth causing her pain she didn't want
to go to the hospital she said her dog
was her show but when additional
officers arrive on the scene they know
montoya's injuries are more extensive
than just a bloody face so he's clear
but uh fire sand either am harney's
transport him or we do he has a bunch of
lumps on his head a bunch of lumps yeah
from when they took him down he probably
didn't say it on the asphalt I guess
video then shows Cullison explaining the
injuries I mean initially it wasn't bad
it kind of wrestling into the ground I
mean it wasn't bad when he started to
resist
Pueblo Police are now recommending a
third degree assault charge for both
Doug and Nate Cullison in montoya's
beating Montoya also faces a third
degree assault charge in the beating of
Collison's wife reporting for a long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie